all right let's go to jamie in atlanta
georgia jamie what's going on
what's going on dr john just rocking and
rolling brother how can i help
um so i guess we'll dive right in let's
do it now
so about five years ago uh
i was uh i was on drugs really bad
with uh my son's mother um
and uh they were all the fun things
they're not really fun that's that's a
really bad joke
and uh she she was able to quit i was
not i was not able to quit at the time i
couldn't uh i couldn't do it
and um so things got progressively where
she left
uh which was the right definitely the
right move to make she left
and uh i was still in georgia
she left and went back to wisconsin
which we moved from
there to here and i moved from here to
there before all of that
and uh i ended up going to jail several
times
and in one of those times going i was
able to have
what we call the vital spiritual
experience that was enough to uh
to this day i have not found it
necessary to take any mind altering
substance
awesome past three years good for you
man so you're 36 months in
yeah oh well over that it's september
22nd 2017.
congratulations brother that's a big
deal man um
and uh hold on you have to acknowledge
that that's a big deal
right i appreciate it i appreciate it
thank you okay
all right so
i've done everything i will work out a
big book of alcoholics anonymous and you
know it says in there you know
uh you know we write it on us letter if
they they won't hear us right so i wrote
an office letter
talked to her multiple times and every
time
um even in the times where she's like
her our uh our son is four now
um and uh i've never seen him i was in
jail when he was born she moved back up
to wisconsin
for good reason i was incredibly abusive
okay um
and uh you know it's just uh
every time she says you know it's always
the same response it's gotten to the
point where it's always the same
responses you've never seen him you're
just a sperm donor
um he has a dad now he doesn't we don't
need you
you're not even a part of his life and
then the last time i sent a letter i
wrote a letter out
i have people proofread it make sure
that i wasn't saying anything offensive
or too selfish or anything like that but
just you know
and uh you know she responded back at
first with
uh because i pay child support um i'm up
to date on child support i make sure you
know
as i'm supposed to because it's the
right thing to do is what i want to do
um and uh you know
uh she said well if you go to court you
know you'll get drug tests but you'll
probably get vegetation that's the best
i can do
and i was about to say like okay or
something then she responds back with
you know how her parents left her
because she was adopted
um and her parents never got off drugs
and never came to go see her
and she voiced that to me along with all
the other things too which i have 100
admitted that that is what it is and i
told her i was like look i will go to a
counselor
i will tell them everything that i did
to you every wrong i'll tell everything
that i did to anything else but we gotta
say we gotta do that
that'll be fine and then all of it's to
no avail the closest thing was her
saying
to go through the court system so
you know i'm just kind of at an impasse
with it you know i've talked to plenty
of people about it you know and it's
just
so what's what is the common advice
you're getting
well um it's actually none of it's
common
to be honest with you it's all different
uh
a lot like my sponsor is like man you
need to just pray about it and let god
work that out you've done the best
you pulled you're into the bargain or
whatever and i i don't feel that that's
sufficient and then i have another
person who says
jim you need to be ready to uh you've
never been a part of this child's life
or anything like that
are you ready and willing to accept it
if you are not allowed to be if this is
not your place
and like i said yes and i guess yes is
the thing but have i explored every
avenue you know what i mean
right is that is that the really the
final answer here is that
is that i don't i don't i don't you know
is it me being selfish i don't know
you know yeah it's something that i wrap
my brain with
all the time brother listen there's not
a selfish
that's the wrong word when it comes to
your kid right
parents who are selfish with their kids
right if you were still using and that
kid lived with you
if um you were blowing rent
on you know partying with your buddies
or whatever
then that would be selfish wanting to
track down your son
after you've been healed for three years
or you're you know you learn
some new ways of of getting through some
of the hard stuff in life
um seeking forgiveness that's not
selfish that's you chasing your son
okay um so
just in the few things you've told me
your wife
um man she's got demons from when she
was a kid that i don't blame her for a
second for
right she had parents that walked out on
her she's lived that road
who knows the trauma she's carrying on
in her heart and mind i don't blame her
for a second you said you're abusive
tell me about that
um i was both physically and uh verbally
abusive
okay did she ever call the police on you
is that why you went to jail or did you
go to jail for using no
no she never did i went to jail uh for
using after
we had moved down here okay and she had
left you know she gave me the ultimatum
you know she told me at one point i
remember uh this is my part of the
supreme sacrifice you know she said uh
you know if you could just quit you know
everything be all right and you know i
made that promise and
30 minutes later it's like it says you
know i couldn't bring in the sufficient
memory the pain of a week or a month ago
and
before i knew it it was already too late
and uh
i had gone back to doing what i had
always done since
since for a long time so why did you get
clean man
uh yes but at first you know
i was i was since the drug court so i
couldn't leave the state for the first
year and a half two years um and i got
i just had a guy listen to me out front
of the clubhouse that i stayed at that
was my home group for a long time and he
listened to me
and you know i was just offered it was a
lot of it's god's grace man like i can't
explain it any other way
no no no not how why
why are you clean now because i'm sick
of it man
i just and i didn't like and now i have
something that works
you know what i mean like i i 100
believe
that at that point in time i was
powerless and i was a slave
i was an absolute slave to everything
that i was doing i had i had no way to
work through it and nor could i see
if there was a way right and today you
know i've been given somebody
sat down and worked with me and gave me
the power to take control of my life
and to live by a principles that don't
allow for excuses
and that don't allow for me to go back
to that way okay no matter how hard it
is no matter whether i'm crying on the
floor
wondering why why why or anything like
that like i don't ever have to go back
to that today
and that's so i choose that you know and
i mean wake up in the morning i'm like
oh nope this is way
way better yeah absolutely so
here's the here's the bottom line if i'm
you
and i have my little boy out there i'm
gonna
move heaven on earth try to see my boy
and at this point um
he does have a man who stepped up in his
life i'm assuming she's remarried
now is that fair well we were never
married okay is she married now
i i do not know okay i don't think so
but i don't know
okay um you mentioned she had a dad
in there in his life now yeah her
adoptive parents
uh took care took care of her okay you
know she has she has a very good support
group
did you sign custody over for him i did
while i was in jail
okay um
i man without getting into your back
story
too deeply and we would need some time
to sit down and go through this
here's what i'm telling you what i would
do
there are a few things on planet earth
more important to me than my son
and i would move heaven and earth to do
that
there's a part of me that thinks that
your wife
still loves you and cares about you but
you beat her up man
you scared her you left her alone and
that is
that fear it's not even a fear that
meant those memories
those experiences override any feeling
she has
and it's at some point it feels like
she's asking you i'm gonna see how far
you're gonna go
right and so what i'm telling you this
may not be the
the most sound legal advice this may not
be the most sound
big book advice okay i'm just telling
you guide a guy what i would do and i've
got a son
a young son myself i would call every
lawyer i could find
i would do whatever i had to do
to be in my son's life i would be
sending my son
probably a weekly letter
so and now you're playing both a short
game and a long game
okay number one at some point you're
gonna have this conversation more than
once with your son about
who you used to be and you
want to have a track record where i son
i chased you to the ends of the earth
i wrote you every week i screwed up your
dad was sick your dad was
acting the fool that your dad didn't
have the right tools
and who knows what your trauma is like
you may be able to teach him a lot about
what you experienced as a young guy
right all that to say is that will come
over time so you're playing a long
relational game what you're aiming for
right now
is that when you're 50 and he's whatever
30 35
that y'all are hanging out together that
you get to go see your grandkids
okay you're not you're not shooting for
everything to be rosy and hunky dory
because this four-year-old little boy
has no idea who you are
right and so i want to have a co
i want to constantly be reaching out to
him and his mom is right to protect him
right now
and um but i you can't control what she
does you control what you do
so i want to write a letter to him every
week and mail it to him
and hopefully she'll read it to him and
if he gets older he'll read it you can
draw on pictures whatever that's going
to look like for him
the second thing is man i'd be on the
phone with a lawyer tomorrow and say man
i screwed up
i signed over stuff when i was in jail
and i want to go meet my son and i
honestly
mean you're talking between states
you're talking i don't know what your
full criminal history is i don't know
any of that stuff and so i don't know
the legal ramifications how that would
actually get together if you would have
to move to wisconsin to have
i don't know any of that stuff what i'm
telling you what i would do
is whatever i had to do to hold my son
right and then just know it's going to
be a
slow slow process of rebuilding trust
and rebuilding trust and those days are
going to feel agonizingly slow
you're going to have seasons where you
are you weep you're going to have
seasons where
you want to punch a hole in something
and you're going to have to constantly
be practicing those new skills that
you've picked up over the last 37 38
months
right and you're playing a long long
game you're raising a man
and you're both healing and you're
healing one too right at the same time
you're right all right so tell me why
you want to see your son again man
you know it's not not again why you want
to see him period
you signed away your name you said he's
better off without me i'm out
why do you want into his life because
even if at that time i mean even if my
thought was
he's better off without me even today
even if he has a new dad you know what i
mean like i'm not there to interject
in between all that that's literally the
last thing i want to do it's not but
if there's ever a time where they can't
do something you know what i mean i'm
not
saying i'm not challenging their
capacity to take care of him
but if there's ever a time where it
might be useful for somebody who has the
proper motivation
to show up when nobody else is able to
show up i can do that i have that
motivation
you know i mean i really feel that you
know what i mean like i don't
i know that i messed up in that sense
you know i understand it i i've worked
through it i put it on paper
i see it you know i own that but
you know it never hurts to have somebody
who is who would drop
everything they're doing if i'm at work
if i gotta fly up there if
there's a hospital thing if they're you
know what i mean if there's a covid
listen listen you're giving me a bunch
of things
you're giving me a bunch of tasks you're
giving me a bunch of achievements
a bunch of accomplishments those are all
good and they're all noble
but when somebody asks you hey why do
you want to see your son
i want to hear you say because i love
that kid i've never even met him
because there's a piece of my heart
beating out there somewhere in wisconsin
and i got to meet him i got to know him
and i gotta love him
and i gotta make sure that he never goes
to bed at night not knowing
that his daddy loves him right
and those other things that you
mentioned those are all derivatives of
that right
because you love him because you've got
a piece of your heart beating somewhere
else out in the universe
that's why you're gonna show up right
that's why you're gonna go see a lawyer
and probably have to work overtime to
pay for that or pick up a second job to
cover that cost
that's why you're gonna have to get in
front of a jury or in front of a judge
and
say the things out loud that you did
right
and you're gonna have to risk being told
by a judge you cannot see your son
right right and that's all risk and
that's all
scary that's all freak out time right
but
all of that is the why is because i want
to see my son
right yeah i want to see my son i love
him
i never have even seen him
and that's going to be what drives you
over the long term and here's the thing
my promise to you brother
let's say the judge says no like i can't
relieve that past i can't put that
trauma back on mom
i don't know that that's the case i
would doubt it but who knows
there will come a day when he comes
looking for whose dad
is there will come a day technology has
gotten to a point where he's going to do
23andme he's going to get on facebook
he's going to figure out who dad is
right and i want there for y'all to
i want there to be a track record like i
said earlier i want there to be
a a bread crumb trail
right back to your heart that said i
wrote you a letter every
week for 14 years before you turned 18
or allowed to come see me
i saved money for your college
and i never even got to see you for 18
years but i knew
that there was going to come a day when
you were going to come meet me and i
wanted to be able at least you may not
want to talk to me at all
but i want you to know when all else
burns to the ground
your daddy loved you and your dad was a
wreck and a
mess and a broken guy and i'm healed and
i'm whole
and hey look i've got i'm married now i
got kids whatever your situation is
but son i kept chasing you and i kept
chasing you and i
kept chasing you right
so yeah man um i'm on the phone today
i'm on the phone first thing eight
o'clock tomorrow morning trying to get a
lawyer that i can afford
that's gonna be excellent that's not
gonna go to war with my wife
i mean my my ex right with my son's mom
i'm not going to war
i'm not trying to burn anything down but
i want to find out
every option i've got to go see my son
and here's the thing i want to keep in
in your heart mind
be honest every step of the way i want
to applaud you for your honesty here
for your healing you got to move forward
you did some stuff that was ugly and
despicable and gross i'm not going to
beat you up for it you know
and now it's about putting the bricks
down brother and then running off into
the
into the light right running forward so
man i love your heart jamie go find him
and
go find your son if you are able to
check in with him i want you to give me
a shout back i want to know how that
reunion goes
if you're not able to give me a call
back and we'll walk through what next
right
because these things don't always have a
pot of gold within this rainbow man
sometimes these things do not have a
happy ending so
thank you so much for your call brother